let's have a look at part b together
second last question show that and
you've got this messy looking integral
on the left hand side look at that
terrible integrand but apparently
somehow if we do this right it's all
going to beautifully simplify down into
log 2 so how can we get there well
hopefully you recognized even without
any clues or hints that this is a
classic partial fractions decomposition
it's true that this fraction on the
left-hand side looks horrendous but
because the denominator has been very
nicely factorized to for you in three
linear factors this is actually very
straightforward to break into three
partial fractions
those partial fractions which each
integrate into a log
and it will actually be pretty
straightforward to do even if it's a
somewhat long question so let's have a
go this is part b
and what we want to find is uh this 3x
plus 7 all divided by
it's x 1
x 2
x 3
and what we want to do is we want to
state that as three separate fractions
one which is an x plus one
one which is an x plus two and another
one which is an x plus 3. now because
this these are all linear factors i
don't need to worry about introducing
any i don't have to worry about
quadratic factors which will have linear
denominators so therefore i can just
call them all constant ah did i say
denominators i think i'm meant to say
numerators i don't have to worry about
linear numerators i just need constant
numerators so i'm going to call this
capital a capital b capital c
all right how do i do this well there is
one horrendous messy looking line which
is the one that combines everything
together so if you take everything on
the right hand side and you mash them
all together you're going to get a
times x plus 2x plus 3
then you're going to get b
times x plus
1 x plus 3
and then lastly am i going to have space
i think so c times x plus 1
x plus 2 and all of that will be divided
by
the original denominator that we started
with on the left hand side
now at this point here you had a couple
of choices
and i'm going to make a case for the
choice that i'm about to make
the first option which is what i'm about
to do is i'm going to choose appropriate
values of x that will make things cancel
out
if i just consider the numerators
and not worry about the fact that i've
got things on the denominators i can let
x equal particular values that make lots
of things cancel
and then i can just get a get b get c
and then off i go
another way of doing this is to just
have a look at this whole whoopsie daisy
look at this whole numerator and if you
expanded this whole thing out right
you're going to get some
quadratics you're gonna get some x
squareds right those x squareds will
have some a's and some b's and some c's
attached the x terms will have some a's
and b's and c's attached and the same
with the constant terms and you could
then compare the x squareds and the x's
and the constants on the right hand side
with the ones on the left
there's not going to be any x squared
term so you could say that that's 0.
whatever x terms on the right hand side
they should add up to 3 and whatever
constant term on the right hand side
that should add up to 7 right you could
do it that way too
the problem is with that second method
is you're going to create a set of three
simultaneous equations with three
variables it's not impossible to solve
it's just a mess and as i was saying in
the previous question very error prone
so most people who tried
to pull a trick like that um ended up
sort of getting themselves into an
algebraic tangle so i'm instead going to
say let's have a look at these
numerators
so i'm going to say
let's consider
these two objects which should be equal
to each other because the denominators
are the same should just be the
numerators that really make the
difference so what am i going to do well
i'm going to choose values of x that
work for me
so for example if you have a think
what's a value of x that will let me get
a by itself will eliminate the b and the
c and hopefully you're seeing
see that if you
notice the x plus one factor that's
attached to the b and the c if you put
in x equals negative one then those are
just going to become zero and therefore
b and c will just disappear completely
and they'll just leave you with a so i'm
going to say
and i'm going to do this again for b and
for c so i'm going to go x equals
negative 1. what does that give me on
the left hand side
negative 3 plus 7. and then on the right
hand side it's going to give me a times
what and the answer is
it's going to be
this is going to be a 1 and this is
going to be a 2. so it's going to be 1
times 2. and so a is just going to be by
itself as uh
4 divided by 2. i guess i should say 2a
equals 4 so a equals 2. i'm done and i'm
just going to pull this same trick over
and hover for b and for c i'm going to
do x equals negative 2.
so what's that going to give me on the
left hand side it's going to give me
negative 6 plus 7. on the right hand
side it's going to give me b remember
all the a and c terms will disappear so
when you pop that in it's going to give
you
negative 1
times 2
no sorry take that back that's a
negative 1 times 1 because i'm
substituting it into there
and then you can see here um on the left
hand side uh or i'll put that minus b
and then on the right hand side negative
six plus seven is one so b
just gives you negative one
once more with feeling pop in x equals
negative 3. uh what am i going to get so
i get 9 minus 9 plus 7 is equal to c
outside of that looks like negative 2
times
1. yeah that looks like it's okay to me
oh no that's a negative one actually
see how easy it is to make these
mistakes with negative signs okay uh and
then let's see here so you're going to
get 2c
equals negative 2 so c is also equal to
negative 1 just like b okay so that was
kind of like one half of the question
and this is a four mark question so
literally two marks were associated with
this amount of work to get the partial
fractions as i mentioned before you
could totally do this you know you'd get
a line something like this uh you're
going to have a outside of x squared
plus 5x plus 6
plus b outside of x squared plus 4x plus
3
plus c outside of x squared plus 3x plus
2. so you would then say well have a
look um look at the x squared terms
right there's going to be a x squared
here b x squared here and c x squared
there so a plus b plus c should equal 0
because there are no x squared terms on
the left then you would say
5ax
4bx
3cx those are all the x terms so they
should be paired up with the 3x so 5a
plus 4b plus 3c will give you three and
then you repeat that process for the
constants it totally works it is just
long and error-prone so i'm not going to
do it now i'm going to proceed to the
integration
i've found what a and b and c are so
therefore i can say therefore
the integral from what am i going from
from naught to one
not to one of three x plus seven
all divided by
x plus one
x plus two
x plus 3 with respect to x i can now
break that into those three integrals
that i saw before so all rather those
three fractions that i saw before which
will give me three integrals in a second
so 0 to 1 our a was 2
so that's 2 on x plus 1
i'm going to have minus 1 on x plus 2
minus 1 on x plus 3 and then all of that
is with respect to x
when you're having a go at that you can
then see um this is not a hard thing to
integrate right you're going to have
here's my square bracket 2
log of x plus 1
minus a single log of x plus 2
minus a single log of x plus three
and then i'm going from naught to one
and now i've just got i've done the
integration right and now i've just got
to substitute and simplify and remember
don't skip any steps because the actual
result that you're going to end up with
is already known so i can't just do some
awesome like cancelling in my head and
say oh it must be this because the
result was given to you so you can't
skip anything when it's that kind of
situation
all right let's do upper bound take away
lower bound so it looks to me like i'm
going to get
2 log 2. let's put another set of
brackets here shall we
2 log 2 minus
log of 3
minus log of
4. there's the upper bound and then i'm
going to subtract and we'll put in 0 for
everything so i'm going to get 2
log 1
minus log of 2
minus log of 3.
there you go there's my substitution now
look carefully right you can see there's
going to be some things that cancel and
some things that don't keep your eye on
this log 2 because we know that's going
to be the final answer if you look
closely you can see
there's a minus log 3 here
and then there is a
double negative minus minus log 3 here
so that's going to become a plus log 3
so those two are going to cancel
if you have a look at this log 1 term
log of 1 is 0. so that's gone and
because i know that this thing is going
to stick around and it's already the
right sign you can see that double
negative there that means that these two
have to cancel how does that work and
the answer is you need to remember your
log laws and again don't skip any steps
here right 2 log 2 i'm going to write
that as log of 2 squared right because
that's what we can do with the power law
of that index right
the log 3 and log 3 can cancel i'm fine
with that that leaves me with a minus
log 4.
then i'm going to subtract i'm not
skipping anything here the 0 take away
log two that was left there and from
here i've got log four take away log
four
double negative for the log oops it does
you don't need that zero anymore log two
and there is the log two as required so
let me make a final note before i leave
off of this question this was a show
question right it wasn't find out what
this integral is equal to
we told you what it was equal to is
equal to log 2. now what that means is
if you made a mistake earlier on by
decomposing your partial fractions
incorrectly if you went through this
integration and
did something wrong or even actually did
something right but with the wrong
numbers because your partial fractions
were incorrect if you ended up at some
line around like here or here as you
were evaluating you were substituting in
the upper and lower bounds
and you were clearly not getting log two
that is a massive indicator to you that
you should go back and fix up your error
something went wrong they told you what
the answer was we told you what the
answer was so that you could fix it okay
um we are less forgiving when we give
you the answer and you try and say yeah
yeah i'm just going to fudge it and say
like oh that must be log 2 right now
that's not how it works right us giving
that result is meant to be a hand for
you a hint to be able to say if you make
a mistake because there's a lot of
working here and lots of places for
numerical areas to creep in
this is an easy escape hatch for you to
work out if something's gone wrong i can
fix it so please be really careful and
use the help that's been provided to you